Last time,
as you'll remember,
we talked about a general overview of the three pen dynamics as well as the
impact of the plague bacteria,
which we have here.
You're sending a pestos the star of our show on the individual human body.
This morning I'd like to talk about community responses to bubonic plague first
in terms of orders that is unorganized,
spontaneous responses.
And then I'd like to look at something really decisive,
which was organized community responses.
That is the first form of successful public health ever devised and the first
victory over a human disease over bluebonnet plague.
So that's where we're headed this morning.
And just so you'll remember,
play gives not a disease entirely of the past.
The third pandemic reached these shores and I wanted to remind you that plague
is still with us and these are the areas in the United States we're play.
Got The present day is endemic among wild rodents and it causes every year a
small trickle of,
uh,
cases of bubonic plague,
usually in the southwest of the United States will in terms of community
responses,
probably the first
and most spontaneous of all was flight panic and fear of sudden death led people
to depart in haste as the film makes clear,
those who are the first to flee where people of means and those often included
the authorities and physicians themselves and clergyman,
thereby increasing disruption and chaos and magnifying the sense of terror.
I imagine you could,
uh,
for an equivalent,
if you were to wake up tomorrow morning and here that there was something
terrible on the medical front happening in new haven and that Stefano and Rick
Levin had taken the last train out.
I can imagine some of the responses that you might have.
In any case,
let's remember the atmosphere in a city visited by the plague.
The last time you heard a description of Florence and 1348 provided by Boccaccio
and you're now reading,
uh,
about to phone and London in 1665.
So let me give you a different,
and also dramatic example.
And that was Naples in 1656 Naples,
one of the largest cities in Europe,
especially vulnerable because of its urban poverty and overcrowding and its
status as one of Europe's great port cities.
It had in 1656 the year of this terrible visitation,
a population of 500,000 an enormous city by 17th century standards and 300,000
people died no less in this visitation.
Every activity in Naples ceased at the time there was general unemployment and
universal hunger.
The living as in the cliche,
weren't sufficiently numerous to bury the dead.
And I mean not literally,
cadavers were left,
not only endures,
but in all public places.
In the end,
some 60,000 bodies were burned and pyres and 20,000 more were unceremoniously
dumped into the sea.
So imagine a great city then with the intolerable stench of decomposition with
dogs,
vultures and Ravens picking it cadavers and a total breakdown of law and order
and of Republic Service.
Imagine to the flight of people the sense that the end of the world was at hand.
And indeed,
one of the popular images of the plague and art was a block figure on horseback,
one of the dread horsemen of the apocalypse who would come on this final day of
reckoning.
So it was from places like this that everyone who could took to the roads often
with the fear in their hearts that God and his anger were in hot pursuit.
So the first spontaneous reaction was to escape.
But remember what we said about here,
moralism,
Hippocrates and Galen,
and if you'll remember then looking back,
medical theory at the time sanctioned this particular reaction or led to it
logically because epidemics and humoral theory,
as you now know,
were caused by an imbalance in the humors triggered by a poisoned air.
One of the six are naturals,
a miasma.
In other words,
the disease was tied to the air around a given locality.
And so it made perfect good sense by the medical theory that people had
inherited,
that they should escape the locale.
And therefore,
the poisonous my answer,
man.
So the response of populations was mediated by the ideas that people had in
their heads.
By the ways an epidemic was understood or an a fashionable modern phrase,
how it was socially constructed.
Now,
orthodoxy was spawned in particular with an idea of what's called Miasma TISM.
That is to say there was a Miasma,
which is derived from the Greek word for corrupted or defiled.
A miasma was a corruption,
uh,
define what or poisoning of the air poisonous Adams emitted by rotting organic
matter of infected people.
And the objects they had touched were released,
became an a flew via in the air,
which was poisoned their by,
and once the air had been made poisonous,
it could be absorbed by anyone in the locality through the pores and the skin
perhaps,
or by being inhaled.
So the body would then be poisoned like the air.
And so the search in the city was for a corrupting agent.
So what did people who had this idea,
this medical philosophy of Boob onic plague?
Where would their suspicions alight?
Well,
first there would fall on foul odors and these were plentiful and an early
modern city.
There was the night soil that people hurled from their windows and doors that
you awful that butchers swept into the streets.
There was the products,
the noxious products of stinking trades like metal or leather working or the
reading of him and so on.
This meant that there were,
the logical consequence would be urban cleanups and saw authorities ordered
cleanups,
collect,
collected,
refuse,
close down certain workshops and trades,
cleanse the streets,
halted work and Abbott wars and ordered the prompt burial of cadavers.
Furthermore,
and Christian Europe water had a symbolic,
we like ritual cleansing attached to it.
It was a purifying quality because of its role in baptism where it cleanses the
soul.
So throughout Europe,
cities ordered their streets cleansed with water in times of plague.
They did more though than just cleanse the streets.
They tried also to cleanse the air directly and so there were bonfires that were
set,
especially with Aaron Mattick would like pine or with software and there was the
firing of Canon with the idea that this too would purify the air.
Those were authorities who took those measures.
There were also ideas of individual self protection and since the cause of the
plague was this horrible poisoned air around you,
it was a good idea to have a little file of aromatic spices around your neck or
it might be vinegar and tobacco had a certain popularity as people smoked their
way to health in the 17th century.
It was also wise to shut up windows indoors if you're indoors to prevent the
poison from entering your home.
The garments of people who were infected also fell under suspicion because the
miasmatic poison was held to cling to them.
Uh,
just as you know,
in your own experience,
the scent of tobacco or perfume can cling to address a sweater or a shirt.
Well,
for this reason people also try to protect themselves with special plague
costumes.
Um,
uh,
you can see you,
it'd be very handsome,
a dress like that and the idea was not the costume would be waxed,
uh,
because that would prevent anything adhering to it.
In this case,
they weren't thinking about fleas.
They were thinking about the outcomes of the corrupted defiled atmosphere.
And you'll note that there's a prominent feature is the beak here.
Uh,
and it's not because it's a bird,
it's the idea was that in the beak you would fill it with our,
with Herb's,
uh,
that were spicy and would protect you that way.
And you'll notice that the person is carrying a rod and that's not for
instructive purposes.
That's to keep people away,
uh,
at a safe distance from you.
So what better way than to be a bit like a verger or let me show you another
example.
Uh,
in here you might have a,
your own brasier of coal that's burning and you might have,
so for,
or something else that would sent the atmosphere around you and always of course
you would have your stick to keep people at a good safe distance to you.
You also took other precautions.
You would approach a plague victim if you suspected that you were encountering
one upwind.
And it was said that plague victims could be approached if you stayed up wind
and kept your distance.
But for those who approached downwind,
illness was likely and the outcome would depend on a body's susceptibility.
On its organic that would determine the balance.
So the four bodily humors,
if the balance was precarious and he small influence that discourage the APP,
Librium could be fatal such as fear,
a dissolute lifestyle,
a sudden shill.
But this idea of cleansing in early modern Europe could also have more sinister
and ritualistic possibilities.
Then these were derived from ancient popular ideas of magic,
of God's anger and punishment for sin.
In other words,
the contamination,
it was thought off by many people could have moral causes which had stirred the
divine wrath.
So vigilant community might well trying to identify and cast out those who were
morally responsible for the calamity.
Sin could be the abuse of food and drink,
excessive sleep and idleness in moderate,
in natural,
unnatural or sinful sex or blasphemous religious practices and beliefs.
So let me show you this rather terrifying slide by Zhu lo ne of 1869 which is
called the plague of Rome.
And it refers to the Rome Clegg in the 17th century,
a major epidemic.
And what we see here is the angel of God pointing out to the event [inaudible]
angel,
the home of a center and the plague is about to destroy the centers and side.
This is the idea that people had in their heads.
So with that idea who might be inside,
well,
suspicion felt on prostitutes for example,
and they were rounded up in many places and expelled from towns and brothels
were closed.
It might fall also on infidels,
religious dissenters,
Jews and Gypsies.
There might be a tax on foreigners and outsiders,
which is and lepers who were already suspected of being grievous sinners.
Or for people who had the view that predestination could be seen by your outward
success in life,
whether you were the elect or not was visible by your worldly wealth then
beggars by their poverty and misfortunes.
We're seen as having already received a first installment of the punishment they
deserve for their secret sins.
So in towns throughout Europe closed themselves to outsiders and inside the
towns,
undesirables might be rounded up and expelled,
or we're still in some places there were stonings lynchings,
burnings.
If the stay full scale pogroms or what we might today call ethnic cleansing.
The poisoning hysteria reinforced this idea and there was often a hysteria that
what the poisoning and the atmosphere was not a natural event,
but a crime.
And there were anointed is called [inaudible] or poisoners who are out to
destroy people.
This was a diabolical plot.
And so a hunt was off and on to find the culprits.
Let me give two famous and notorious examples.
Uh,
first an early one,
it's straws.
Borg in the 14th century were rumor had it,
you'll remember in the 14th century,
the Jews were cast out of the Iberian peninsula.
And the,
uh,
panic fear was that they were carrying out a plot as vengeance to destroy
Christian Europe by poisoning the wells of Christendom.
So crowds at straws,
Borg rounded up 8,000 Jews took them to the Jewish cemetery and burn them alive.
Or let me tell you another example from Milan and 1630 and not really a more
cheerful one at all,
although on a smaller scale and it's told in one of the two actually of the
great works by the inventor of the Italian novel and one of the Great European
novelists of the 19th century,
Alessandro Manzoni,
the novel is called the patrol.
And he also wrote a historical work called the column of Infamy.
That is to say Milan.
And here's a picture of the event I want to tell you about as described by
Manzoni acting as a historian.
The city of Milan in 1630 was at war with Spain and to their misfortune for
hapless Spaniards were found in the city just as plague was breaking out and
they were accused of starting it by spreading poisonous ointment on the doors of
the houses of the city under torture.
They confessed to the crime and were convicted of high treason and then sentence
to have their hands cut off to be broken on the wheel and then burned on this at
the stake.
So at the site of their execution and hence the term we have this,
which is the column of infamy.
You can see the uh,
prisoners being brought and you can see there being broken on the wheel and all
the rest of it in the picture.
And you can also see that there was erected here,
the chief criminal Jacob Maury mortar and uh,
on the site in Milan after the plague apply was posted.
The column was meant to deter anyone else from ever doing something so
diabolical.
And this plaque was placed in Latin saying what had happened and what the
punishment had been and warning people to commemorate this event that no house
should ever be built on this site.
So this was,
and this is the inscription on the plot.
So those were reactions.
Another reaction was one of mass repentance to Preetish propitiate an angry
divinity.
And to do that,
how did you go about it?
One way was by outdoor per sessions,
confessing your sins,
repenting and urging your neighbors and everyone else you encountered to do the
same.
There were religious revivals.
The play gears were marked in particular by a new cult of saints,
the ones held to be most willing to intercede on behalf of humanity and to
divert the divine anger.
There was a great cult of the Virgin Mary.
There was a cult of St Christopher,
but in particular have two new saints who had an extraordinary vogue during the
plague year.
The first was Saint Sebastian and the other was on that ACO or saint rock.
Let me,
uh,
here is Saint Sebastian.
And if you look,
think of the iconography,
you'll remember that when we talked in the first lecture about homer,
we saw the Depaulo took hours to shoot the plague to destroy the Greeks.
And so there has been a constant idea symbolically of arrows as symbols of the
plague.
And Saint Sebastian is someone who was willing to give his life to save his
fellows by absorbing the arrows into his own flesh.
He was martyred by the arrows,
and this was sad to be his way of defending humanity.
So he,
there was a great vogue in this era of Saint Sebastian who was invoked to help
human beings to avoid the plague.
Another was Sung Rocco.
Now who is he?
He was an aristocrat from [inaudible] and according to legend,
he gave his riches away to the poor and set off on a pilgrimage to Italy where
he had the great misfortune of arriving.
And you know,
it was a misfortune and 1348 at the onset of the black death,
he however,
fell ill but survived.
And then he stayed to tend to the hill only eventually to return to France where
he faced arrest and finally died in prison like Saint Sebastian.
He was a man who was held to be willing to sacrifice his body,
his wealth and his life to save the people of God.
So images of these saints,
and we'll look at this next time when we look at the artistic representations,
the legacy of bluebonnet plague on the arts.
Images of these saints in particular proliferated in this period at the
entrances to houses and people's bedrooms and public squares as a protection
against the plague.
And there was a vogue in these saints names that parents gave their children.
Another way to propitiate I said per sessions,
one of the most mysterious movements of the plague,
years in the early time of the third pandemic was a mass movement known as the
flatulence.
Here the adherence vowed to devote themselves for a month to mass pilgrimage and
repentance.
They carried the cross,
they prayed,
they listen to preachers and they underwent public whipping and indeed self
flagellation in order to satisfy God's anger.
And when you come to look at the film by Ingmar Bergman,
the seventh seal,
one of the depictions in not one of them,
uh,
scenes that will be most interesting to you is uh,
the capturing on film a of this procession of the flatulence.
You see them praying,
uh,
and beating themselves and each other with whips.
We,
we'll see next time too that this affected the iconography of European art from
the 14th century through the 17th.
There is a theme we'll see next time of the dance of death,
the so called Dos Macabre,
uh,
of people being rounded up by the grim reaper.
There are also what are called Vanitas symbols,
which are symbols in art of how life is very insecure that it's brief and can,
it can end very predict unpredictably.
Now,
these weren't a school of painting or an artistic style.
They work the iconography,
they were themes that painters depicted.
And it may also be that portraying the disease in this way was it kind of
exorcism of the mysterious scourge.
And this was a powerful reminder of the transients of all things.
There were also popular superstitions in these days from astrology.
There was the belief that certain metals or precious stones,
rubies and diamonds had protective properties against the plague as did certain
magical numbers.
And it won't surprise you that one of the great numbers that you could conjure
with was the number four,
you know,
the drill four elements,
four temperaments,
um,
four evangelists,
four humors,
four winds,
four seasons and so on.
So the number four was very powerful and protective.
Another aspect of plague,
of course,
was that there were people who profited from it,
profiteering,
the great cities and grip of plague.
We're lens of opportunity for rogues of every sort.
So the epidemics of disease broaden their train outbreaks of crime and swindling
thieves plundered the homes of those who had fled.
Remember those who had fled where usually the wealthy and charlatans pedaled,
every variety of magical men are remedies,
wall astrologers sold comfort and advice.
Healers charged astounding sums for practicing.
They're dangerous arts.
Those were forms of spontaneous reaction to play.
What I'd like to do next is to talk instead about something very different that
I promised,
which is organized response by authorities.
And this is the first form of organized public health that eventually leads by
the late 17th and AOD 18th centuries to the first victory of human beings over a
major infectious disease.
So let's look at what those public health measures were.
Well,
empirical observation and time of plague gave rise not only to spontaneous
reactions that we've described,
but also to a new idea that began to spread alongside medical orthodoxy and new
idea,
the idea of contagion that somehow the plague spread in an unspecified manner
from person to person.
This idea was largely rejected for centuries by learned official medicine,
which clung to the older idea of my asthma,
autism of Galen and his system.
But it became an important idea in popular culture and in the thinking of
certain medical heretics.
It was fully developed by Flocka Storto and we've mentioned before of Padua in
Italy in the 16th century,
but also by the German Jesuit Kitcher in the 17th century.
The theory was that of his so called contagion viva them,
which consisted of animal qls of some sort of public policy,
was to deal with flag was first devised in the northern Italian city states in
the 14th and 15th centuries,
places like Florence,
Venice,
Milan,
and genuine,
and then were adopted elsewhere and France and Spain and northern Europe.
What was involved,
as I say,
was momentous,
the world's first system of public health,
and it turned out to be an organizational idea of genius.
The embryo of the system was established during the black death and then became
increasingly sophisticated and comprehensive through the middle of the 16th and
17th and then the 18th centuries.
But the Achilles' heel early on was that the system was narrowly municipal or
local and scope.
A quantum leap was made that turn to make it more effective.
And the 17th and 18th centuries when the idea was taken up by early modern
states that devoted the military power of the state to the effort,
you'll note the operation of magistrates in their power in London as you're
reading defoe in the 17th century.
So the early vision combined by this time with the necessary power over a
sufficiently large area to make success possible.
Now,
an interesting aspect of the situation is this.
The authorities took action,
although there was no medical understanding of war,
at least nothing that we would regard with Rhett retrospectively as an
efficacious understanding of the disease they were facing.
They acted more or less in the dark and in the process took measures that were
sometimes extreme and heavy handed that often wasted resources.
And we're sometimes actually counter productive.
But in the end,
the path they pioneered led to the first victory over a major human disease.
So let's look at the policies.
What were they?
First of all was a new institution originally.
That is,
they were called health magistrates.
Um,
we now know them as boards of health and these magistrates or boards of health
as they came to be known later and are still known.
We're endowed with extraordinary powers during emergencies that gave them,
they combined in their hands a plentitude of legislative,
judicial and executive authority and matters that related to public health.
By the late 16th century cities in the Van Guard of the movement even had
permanent health,
magistrates and their example was followed across Europe.
That was one thing,
a new authority.
Then a second plague measure was compulsory burial.
And there were so many dead and a major epidemic that you wanted to dispose of
them quickly before they poisoned the atmosphere and you couldn't bury them
individually.
And so they were cast into common pits,
plague pits,
and this was followed by the destruction,
by fire of their personal effects and the banning of funerals and funeral
processions abandoning of the laying out and the wake.
And the problem of burial was an important issue.
And every outbreak of plague priests and grave diggers were decimated and there
weren't enough people left then to dispose of the dead in normal ways and it
must be remembered that this generated terror in itself,
the presence of large numbers of unmarried cadavers and as city or the indignity
of disposal of hurling,
newly dead people into improvised pits heightened the horror of the disease.
Another feature of the plague measures was the control of movement,
the control of the movement of people from plague infested regions by quarantine
and squads of soldiers turning people away from city gates and opening fire on
those who tried to cross the line.
Another feature of the to these times was the isolation of the infected in pest
houses known across Europe as lots ciretos or alternatively,
as you know from people were simply shut up together with their families in
their own homes and forbidden to open the door while guards enforced the rule
and being were stationed outside.
Most fearful of all was a measure called general quarantine in which everyone,
an infected infected neighborhood was sealed inside his or her home for 40 days
with watchman outside to arrest or even kill those who tried to escape.
Let me show you a slide.
Um,
well this is actually not the one I had in mind.
This is Marsay and I'm 1720 to 22 during the time of the flag.
And if you look carefully,
you could see,
um,
many of the events that we've been describing taking place in the foreground.
But instead of that,
I'd rather concentrate on this because this has to do with your reading and
Daniel Defoe.
This is London in 1656 that you now know and love and you can see here the bond
fires and attempt to purify the air.
You can see these are watchman stationed outside to prevent people leaving.
There has houses and you can see the homes that have shut up and sealed with
people inside are marked.
But these are the homes of plague victims.
So those were important,
those regulations.
Then there were lots of rest to us.
The pest houses,
and these shouldn't be confused with modern hospitals.
There weren't places if cure,
but rather barrack like places of horror and death were inmates died on mass
where people were locked up,
not so much to be cured,
but to spare the city of the danger of inhaling deadly vapors from their
contaminated.
Bonnie's the pest house was really the anti chamber to eternity.
And the word lots of recto comes from the biblical reference to Lazarus who was
raised from the dead.
In any case,
let me show you a slide of a lots of recto.
This is a picture from the 19th century by Goodall of Napoleon in the pest house
of Jaffa.
And this is,
um,
a picture by 10 to her death to all of whom will see much more next time.
This is Sun Ra called member.
I promised you Sung Rocco who stayed behind,
uh,
who visited Italy and time of plague and fell ill himself,
revived and stayed behind to 10,
the dead or dying.
And here we see him in the lots of Modesto,
which is pretty much a place of dread and horror.
And people were conveyed there and this was important to buy carters and the
carters also inspired fear.
People were forcibly gathered up and her old into their mournful heaving
conveyances and these were dreaded almost as much as the ds themselves.
This fear often was due to the fact that these petty officials risk their lives
and an as an investment through extortion,
healthy men and women could be threatened.
The ill could be blocked,
mailed so they could be left to die at peace in their homes.
Burglars could be sold information on empty houses and often they were drunk as
they consume spirits to fortify their courage.
Another part of the plague and regulations was the control of markets and
provisions to guarantee the supply of food to an afflicted locality so that
people wouldn't die of famine as well as disease.
The health magistrates or boards of health had also the power to close brothels
and arrest prostitutes.
As I've said,
they often attempted to purify the corrupted atmosphere with bonfires and with
sulfur and gunpowder well taken together.
All of these plague measures were a draconian and when first applied they
probably increased fear and chaos,
promoted flight by people desperate not to be locked in a dying city or Carter
to way to [inaudible] house.
And this may have assisted the spread of plague itself.
Anti plague regulations were causes of suffering and they often met in various
parts of Europe with fierce opposition and cause civil disturbance and social
tensions.
They involve the infinite horror of the pest house,
the separation of family members,
the burning of precious possessions,
the Prohibition of Processions and gatherings,
the Prohibition of movement,
the closing of markets,
the denial,
a funeral observances.
So from Moscow to London,
all across Europe,
the passage of plague was marked by demographic disaster,
by social tensions and economic disruption.
Great cities took on the appearance of ghost towns and these scenes were
repeated for centuries after 1347 without breaks here and there,
every generation and great European wide pandemics several times a century.
As you know,
the normal pattern was that the plague lay waste to a locality for months and
then the disease Abdin faded away as mysteriously as it began.
And this true left a legacy for the fee for the final departure of the plague
was a sign that God had been appeased and was a testimony to the wisdom of their
repentance and perhaps to their decision to hunt out the guilty.
And there Mitch,
and let me remind you that this still is mark in the landscape of urban Europe.
And I'd like to show you an example and this will be the castells Sant Angelo
right here,
one of the most common tourists sites out in sites of memory and modern rum
today.
That's a general view.
Let's close in a little more closely.
And uh,
here we can see as we're approaching the Costal Sant Angelo,
um,
I want you to see,
so I'll have a next picture.
We'll,
we'll look at the tall,
and this is one of the major landmarks in a major European city today.
And what is it?
It's due to play tag at the top of the castells Sant Angelo is the arch Angel
Gabriel and what he's doing is she thing his sword.
Okay.
As a sign,
the divine wrath had been appeased that God had relented and let the scourge of
the population of Rome was no more.
Okay.
For a modern epidemiologist,
this thinking might be quite different,
but a vital link in the great chain of infection had been broken in the chain of
transmission,
perhaps that the infected population of black routes had been destroyed,
that all of the susceptible members of the human population had already
perished.
That the new onset of winter and cold weather had reduced the activity of fleas.
But in any case,
the point I want to make was that eventually the plague measures and regulations
were or at least seemed to be effective.
Okay.
Especially after the 17th century with the increased military power of an early
modern state that deployed standing armies and naval forces to apply the policy
rigorously and over a substantial territory.
Okay.
Venice provided perhaps the first important example that was soon imitated in
country after country until western Europe was medically isolated by quarantines
lots,
Sorentos and sanitary coordinates.
Let me talk a little more in detail about the Venetian idea of public health.
It was not in Venice was a great port as you know,
that the ports of Europe could be protected by isolation from an invasion by
sea.
To achieve this objective,
the authorities constructed a great fortress on the outline islands to which all
arriving ships from the eastern Mediterranean or directed there.
There were impounded for six weeks while they were scrubbed and fumigated.
Crews and passengers were disembarked at these fortresses and quarantine for 40
days on the cargo and passengers.
Personal effects were unloaded,
turned in the sun,
fumigated in air,
and only at the end of 40 days we're good to ship and passengers released to
enter the city.
It will.
The theory was that by strict quarantine and he pestilential vapors would be
given time to disperse and so the city might be spared.
Well,
let's look at a couple of lots of ref toes.
This is a port call of less spate Sia.
And the point I'm trying to make as if these were very complicated,
uh,
and authoritarian institutions,
their fortresses no less.
This is,
um,
uh,
at Naples,
the island of Neesy Duh.
Or at Marsay.
This is the,
uh,
great,
lots of recto on Faroe Island.
Well,
Sis was simple.
In principle it was a maritime quarantine,
but to be effective,
it presuppose state power.
Uh,
lots of retro was a fortress for thousands of passengers and crew had to be
policed,
provision an isolated from all contacts with the city required the strong naval
presence to,
to compel,
unwilling and possibly terrified sea captains to anchor within these waters and
to prevent attempts at evasion or escape within the lot Sorento,
there were detailed,
complex regulations to ensure that hundreds,
sometimes thousands of passengers in different stages of quarantine would be
isolated,
not only from the city,
but also from each other,
and that the items of the ship's crew would all be properly fumigated and
exposed to the sun.
The idea of quarantine was an empirical result of long experience and its
establishment to be successful.
Presupposed the bureaucratic navel and administrative resources of the early
modern state.
Well,
looking back with modern understanding,
you would probably conclude that the medical theory underlying the Venetian
system of quarantine was flawed by modern standards.
There were no pestilential miasmas and many of the rituals of purification were
to no effect.
But the idea of lengthy and military enforced isolation was highly effective in
practice,
40 days exceeded the incubation period of the disease and so were sufficient to
guarantee that a person then released was medically harmless.
At the same time,
the period of quarantine was long enough to ensure the death of inflected fees,
fleas,
and of the bacterium itself.
So an inaccurate theory produce sound administrative procedures.
The Venetian lots rhetto backed by the Venetian fleet demonstrated that it could
in practice protect the city from disaster and within a generation other than
Mediterranean powers,
imitated the experiment building lots.
Ciretos Naples,
Genoa,
Valencia,
Marsay,
Corfu,
and all ships from the east.
We're compelled to dock them by the end of the 17th century,
the port cities of Europe,
we're no longer some menaced by see the disease continued to be imported,
but what's contained with just two major failures in 1720 bubonic plague spread
from the lots of red toto to the city of Marsay killing 60,000 people.
And then in 1743 the last burst of epidemic plague in Europe at Messina and
Sicily.
Meanwhile,
there was the overland threat and this was seen to by the hops Berg Empire,
which dis do in the course of the 18th century,
initiated in perfected a great permanent cordon sanitaire of soldiers stretching
across the length of the Balkan peninsula.
The Austrian Coordin was 10 to 20 miles wide during threat of plague and 1200
miles long.
It consisted of a great permanent line of soldiers and century posts station to
present people from passing.
So one of the great armies of Europe assume the task of isolating western Europe
from the East Justice,
the Matsuura Ciretos and a buy in the ports isolated it by sea,
thousands of soldiers,
12,000 during time of epidemics.
We're stationed to do that.
And it was the case then by the 18th century,
bubonic plague,
the scourge of five centuries was entirely eliminated and didn't return to
western Europe.
Let me look.
Uh,
this was a slide of a,
it could be anywhere.
It happens to be the city of Bari and you can see the cordon of soldiers
surrounding the city and protecting it from bubonic plague.
And it might be sad as well that occasionally the pope reinforce the physical
sanitary coordin with a spiritual one that is threatening anyone who crossed the
line with communication.
Well,
this was the world's first victory and the conquest of disease,
the greatest epidemic disease in European history had been eliminated not by the
advents of medicine or scientific knowledge,
but by the deployment of the military and bureaucratic power of the state or
certainly.
So it seem though we might wonder if other perhaps imponderable factors or also
at work,
the replacement of our friend the block route,
um,
whom you now know and love that was very sociable and like to live close to
human beings by the brown route that was shy and retiring and kept its distance
or there were improved standards of sanitation and hygiene or people talk about
the impact.
Perhaps it was climatic change that was decisive and people point to the little
ice age which began in the 16th century and reached Minima of temperatures,
uh,
about 1650 and again in the 17th seventies and then gave way to warming in the
19th century.
And we see this in works of art in Dutch painting.
The 17th century gave rise to great vogue of winter scenes that you don't really
see in the modern Netherlands when the canals froze in the 17th century and
people were able to skate on them.
And there weren't many other examples of winter scenes of painting.
This was how cold it was in the 17th century.
Indeed,
it's swept all of Europe.
The River Thames froze in London.
The balls took,
froze that one could travel by sled from Poland to Sweden,
and these weren't good conditions for your [inaudible] and the fleas that were
inspectors.
But we've run out of time,
but at least we've contained the plague.
And next time we'll look at its impact on European culture and thought.